in this video I want to do a couple of
inequality problems that are deceptively
tricky and you might be saying hey
aren't all inequality problems
deceptively tricky and on some level
you're you're probably right but let's
start with the first problem we have X
minus 1 X minus 1 over X plus 2 is
greater than 0 and I'm actually going to
show you two ways to do this the first
way is I think on some level the simpler
way but I'll show you both methods and
whatever works for you well it works for
you so the first way you can think about
this if I have just any number any
number divided by any other number and I
say that they're going to be greater
than zero well we just have to remember
our properties of multiplying and
dividing negative numbers in what
situation is this fraction going to be
greater than 0 well this is going to be
greater than 0 only if both a and so we
could write both a is greater than 0 and
B is greater than 0 so this is one
circumstance where this will definitely
be true right we have a positive divided
by a positive it'll definitely be a
positive it'll definitely be greater
than 0 or or we could have the situation
where we have a negative divided by a
negative if we have the same sign
divided by the same sign we're also
going to be positive so or a is less
than 0 and B is less than 0 so whenever
you have any type of rational expression
like this being greater than 0 there's
two situations in which it'll be true
the numerator and the denominator are
both greater than 0 or they're both less
than 0 so let's remember that and
actually do this problem so there's two
situations to solve this problem the
first is where both of them are greater
than 0 if that and that are both greater
than 0 we're cool so we could say our
first solution maybe I'll draw a little
tree like that is X minus 1 greater than
0 and and X plus 2 greater than 0 that's
equivalent to this the top and the
bottom are both if they're both greater
than 0 then when you divide them you're
going to get something greater than 0
the other option we just saw that is if
both of them were less than 0 so the
other option is X minus 1
zero and X plus two less than zero if
both of these are less than zero then
you have a negative divided by negative
which will be positive which will be
greater than zero
so let's actually solve in both of these
circumstances so X minus 1 greater than
0 X minus 1 greater than 0 if we add 1
to both sides of that we get X is
greater than 1 and if we do X plus 2
greater than 0 X plus 2 greater than 0
if we subtract 2 from both sides of that
equation remember I'm doing this right
now
we get X is greater than minus 2 so for
both of these to hold true so in this
little brown or red color or whatever
you want to think of it in order for
both of these to hold true X has to be
greater than 1 and X has to be greater
than minus 2 right this statement we
figured out means that X has to be
greater than 1 and this statement so and
this statement tells us that X has to be
greater than minus 2 now if X is greater
than 1 and X has to be greater than
minus 2 X clearly has to be greater than
1 right I mean you know 0 would not
satisfy this because 0 is greater than
minus 2 but it's not greater than 1 so
for something to be greater than 1 and
minus 2 it has to be greater than 1 so
the whole this whole chain of thought
where I'm saying the numerator and the
denominator are greater than 0 that's
only going to happen if X is greater
than 1 because if X is greater than 1
then X is definitely going to be greater
than negative 2 right any number greater
than 1 is definitely greater than
negative 2 so that's one situation in
which this equation holds true and we
could even try it out let's say X was 2
2 minus 1 is 1 over 2 plus 2 it's 1/4
it's a positive number now let's do the
situation where both of these are
negative if the X minus 1 is less than 0
if we add 1 to both sides of that
equation that tells us so X minus 1 less
than 0 that's the same thing if we add 1
to both sides of that as saying that X
is less than 1 so that constraint boils
down to that constraint now this
constraint X plus 2
is less than zero if we subtract two
from both sides we get X is less than
minus two so this constraint boils down
to that constraint so in order for both
of these guys to be negative both the
numerator and the denominator to be
negative we know that X has to be less
than one and X has to be less than minus
two now if something has to be less than
one and it has to be less than minus two
well it just has to be less than minus
two anything less than minus two is
going to be is going to satisfy both of
these so this boils down to just X could
also be less than minus two and remember
this is an or either both the numerator
and the denominator are positive or or
they're both negative so both of them
being positive boiled down to X could be
greater than one or both of them being
negative boils down to X is less than
minus two so our solution is X could be
greater than one or right X could be
greater than one that's both of these
positive or X is less than minus two
that's both of these negative and if we
wanted to draw it on a number line let
me draw a number line just like that
that could be zero and then we have one
so X could be greater than one not
greater than or equal to so we put a
little circle there to show that we're
not including one and we could
everything greater than one will satisfy
this equation or anything less than
minus two so we have minus one minus two
anything less than minus two will also
satisfy this equation by baking both the
numerator and the denominator by both
making the numerator and the denominator
negative you could try it out minus
three minus three minus one let's do
minus three minus one is equal to minus
4 and then minus three plus two minus
three plus two is equal to minus one
minus four divided by minus one is
positive four so all of these negative
numbers also work now I told you that I
will show you two ways of doing this
problem so let me show you another way
if you
this one may be a little bit confusing
so the other way let me rewrite the
problem you get X minus 1 over X plus 2
is greater than 0 greater than 0 and
actually let's mix it up a little bit
and you could apply the same logic let's
say it's greater than or equal what I'm
going to no no I'll just keep it the
same way and maybe in the next video
I'll do the case where it's greater than
or equal just because I really don't
want to maybe I want to incrementally
step up the level of difficulty so let's
say that we're just saying X minus 1
over X plus 2 is just straight-up
greater than 0 now one thing you might
say is well if I have a rational
expression like this maybe I multiply
both sides of this equation by X plus 2
so I could rid of it in the denominator
and I can multiply it times 0 and get it
out of the way but the problem is when
you multiply both sides of an inequality
by a number if you're multiplying by
positive you can keep the inequality the
same but if you're multiplying by a
negative you have to switch the
inequality and we don't know what
whether X plus 2 is positive or negative
so let's do both situations so let's say
if let's do one situation where X plus 2
let me write it this way X plus 2 is
greater than 0 and then another
situation where let me do that in a
different color where X plus 2 X plus 2
is less than 0 right these are the two
possibilities for X plus 2
actually in no situation can X plus 2
equals 0 if X plus 2 were to be equal to
0 then this whole expression would be
undefined and so that definitely won't
be a situation that we want to deal with
it would be an undefined situation so
these are our two situations when we're
multiplying both sides so if X plus 2 is
greater than 0 that means that X is
greater than minus 2 right we can just
subtract 2 from both sides of this
equation so if X is greater than minus 2
then X plus 2 is greater than 0 and then
we could multiply both sides of this
equation times X plus 2 so you have X
minus 1 over X plus 2 greater than 0 I'm
going to multiply both sides by X plus 2
which I'm assuming as positive because X
is greater than minus
to multiply both sides by X plus 2 these
cancel out 0 times X plus 2 is just 0
and then you have X minus you're just
left with X minus 1 is greater than this
just simplified to 0 solve for X add 1
to both sides you get X is greater than
1 so we saw that if X plus 2 is greater
than 0 or we could say if X is greater
than minus 2 then X also has to be
greater than 1 right or you could say if
X is great well you could go both ways
in that but we say look if both of these
things have to be true if for X to
satisfy both of these it just has to be
greater than 1 because if it's greater
than 1 it's definitely going to satisfy
this constraint over here so this for
this branch we come up with a solution X
is greater than 1 so this is one
situation where X plus 2 is greater than
0 the other situation is X plus 2 being
less than 0 if X plus 2 is less than 0
that's equivalent to saying that X is
less than minus 2 you just subtract 2
from both sides now if X plus 2 is less
than 0 what we'll have to do when we
multiply both sides let's do that we
have X minus 1 over X plus 2 we have
some inequality and then we have a 0 now
if we multiply both sides by X plus 2 X
plus 2 is a negative number when you
multiply both sides of an equation by a
negative number you have to swap the
inequality so this greater than sign
will become a less than sign because
we're assuming that the X plus 2 is
negative these cancel out 0 times
anything is 0 and we get that X minus 1
is less than 0 solving for x adding 1 to
both sides X is less than 1 so in the
case that X plus 2 is less than 0 or X
is less than minus 2 X must be less than
1 well I mean we know if saying if you
say something has to be less than minus
2 and less than 1 just saying that it's
less than minus 2 will do the job right
anything less than minus 2 is going to
satisfy this one but not anything that
satisfies this one is going to satisfy
that one so this is the only constraint
we have to worry about so in the event
where X plus 2 is less than 0 we can
just say that
has to be less than minus two that'll
satisfy this equation so our final
result is X is either going to be
greater than one or X is going to be
less than minus two so once again you
can graph it on the number line X is
greater than one X is greater than one
right there
you have zero minus one minus two and
then you have X is less than minus two
you're not including the minus two and
just like that and that is the exact
same result we got up here so whatever
version you find to be easier but you
can see they're both a little bit
nuanced and you have to think a little
bit about what happens when you multiply
or divide by positive or negative
numbers